buongiorno a tutte buongiorno a tutti il
titolo del mio intervento è quali
periferie il destino il sogno la
possibilità quello che farò in questi
prossimi minuti sarà a dirvi qualche
parola su cosa io penso a proposito del
termine periferie cioè cercherò di dirvi
di che cosa parliamo secondo me quando
parliamo di periferie e parleremo di
cose molto diverse come vedremo
cercherò di dirvi che naturalmente
esiste una specificità del tema delle
periferie che è quella globale le
periferie del mondo che sono anche i
luoghi della povertà più profonda spesso
in terzo luogo mostrerò come però le
periferie siano state anche un sogno per
alcuni e abbiano rappresentato una
speranza e una possibilità e infine
mostrerò con particolare riferimento al
caso milanese quanto le periferie
possano anche essere occasioni
straordinarie per ripensare a rigenerare
le nostre città a certe condizioni
innanzitutto di che cosa parliamo quando
parliamo di periferie la parola come
dice un bel libro del sociologo agostino
petrillo che insegna nella nostra
università
viene dal greco e viene da un verbo il
verbo periferia che vuol dire tracciare
una circonferenza ma anche disegnare un
interno e un esterno includere ed
escludere e le periferie in effetti
prima di tutto sono luoghi di esclusione
di allontanamento da un luogo percepito
come centro però come ho detto prima
quando abbiamo in mente le periferie
abbiamo in mente spesso situazioni e
contesti molto diversi sono periferici
l'islam
naturalmente ma sono periferiche anche
le infinite casette dello sprawl e delle
città americane e periferico il corviale
ma sono periferiche anche le gated
communities di molte città europee o
anche sudamericane nordamericane
insomma le periferie nominano contesti
sociali territoriali paesaggistici molto
molto diversi
alle mie spalle c'è un'immagine di un di
un luogo che a milano è certamente un
luogo tipicamente periferico del
quartiere gratosoglio
io ci sono molto affezionato perché ci
sono nato molto vicino sono un ragazzo
di periferia
e il gratosoglio quando è nato è stato
progettato dagli architetti molto
importanti molto famosi molto bravi
maestri della scuola milanese è stato
costruito sulla base di principi
razionalisti molto forti
e però quando è stato costruito per
esempio non lo raggiungeva alcun mezzo
pubblico era molto lontano dal centro
della città all'estremo confine del
comune di milano prossimo al comune di
rozzano
ecco questo è un tipico luogo nel quale
oggi noi assistiamo insieme a condizioni
anche difficili pesanti di degrado
sociale e spaziale però anche a gruppi
persone organizzazioni che si danno da
fare che ci lavorano che si impegnano
per migliorare le condizioni di vita in
questi luoghi ci tornerò alla fine
naturalmente dobbiamo anche dimentica
non dobbiamo anche dimenticare che le
periferie del mondo sono anche le città
dei poveri sono le città nelle quali
spesso la povertà più estrema e prossima
come in queste immagini molto famose
alla ricchezza bernardo secchi un famoso
urbanista in un libro molto bello che si
chiama appunto la città dei ricchi e la
città dei poveri ci fa capire che
comprendere la città dei poveri senza
comprendere la città di ricky è
impossibile
noi dobbiamo vedere insieme come in
questa immagine che mostra una favela
vicina a un palazzo diciamo per persone
abbienti per persone ricche e quindi non
dobbiamo mai dimenticare
lasciando perdere tutte le retoriche che
le periferie poi sono luoghi e anche
della povertà del disagio più profondo
io sono stato di recente a maputo che è
una città molto importante la capitale
del mozambico nel quale ho visto quelle
che sono le periferie in quei luoghi la
città informale estremamente vitale
certamente estremamente piena di
un'umanità che ha voglia di migliorare
di cambiarsi di modificarsi però non
dobbiamo anche dimenticare che a maputo
e molte altre città del sud del mondo
la condizione di vita e spesso questa ci
sono interi ceti interi gruppi interi
pezzi di società che vivono dentro le
discariche questa è una discarica di
maputo e pochi giorni dopo che ho
lasciato maputo per le piogge questa
discarica una discarica grande di maputo
si è rovesciata su un insediamento
informale sono stati uccise tantissimo
nelle persone questo per dire che non
dobbiamo mai dimenticare questa
dimensione
la dimensione secondo la quale la
condizione di perifericità è anche una
condizione di ingiustizia sociale
l'ingiustizia sociale che spesso si
porta dietro anche una differenza
spaziale però le periferie non sono solo
questa condizione questa situazione con
la situazione non scelta dalle persone
non si decide di vivere così sono anche
luoghi che sono stati a lungo per tanto
tempo da parte di intellettuali
urbanisti architetti sognate come luoghi
possibili sono stati un sogno di città
in sostanza per tutto il ventesimo
secolo
io qui vi mostrerò adesso alcune
immagini di un esempio molto noto molto
famoso si tratta di un grande ensemble a
vicino a parigi in un comune
nell'hinterland parigino costruito
all'inizio degli anni 60 circa 1.600
appartamenti 6 mila persone
costruito nel giro di pochi anni il nome
del quartiere la caravella e questo è un
quartiere costruito secondo dei principi
per i quali le periferie erano il luogo
per abbandonare condizioni insalubri
condizioni negative dei ceti più poveri
e più popolari e questo è vero per
tantissima parte delle periferie in
tutto il mondo vale per tanti luoghi che
abbiamo in mente il corviale di roma lo
zen di palermo lo stesso gratosoglio che
ho mostrato prima e tanti altri sono
luoghi che sono stati pensati e
progettati come luoghi pieni di servizi
con luce con aria rispetto a condizioni
abitative che erano molto più negative
nei quali erano presenti i campi
sportivi nei quali erano presenti
appunto un'ampia parte di servizi
sociali dotazioni di verde eccetera
eccetera
e tuttavia in molti di questi quartieri
in molti di questi luoghi
le condizioni sono peggiorate nel corso
del tempo e sono diventati parte delle
periferie e importante dirlo perché le
periferie non esistono in natura si
diventa periferie la periferia è
qualcosa che nel corso del tempo si
costruisce sulla base di processi
politici economici sociali demografici
ed è importante capire perché in alcuni
casi le cose vanno bene in alcuni casi
le cose vanno male
esempio questo quartiere che è stato
ripeto costruito da un bravissimo
architetto sulla base dei principi della
dell'architettura e dell'urbanistica
razionalistica è diventato un quartiere
ghetto un quartiere nel quale c'è un
processo fortissimo di auto
stigmatizzazione chi abita in questo
quartiere si percepisce come lontano
come distante come privo di opportunità
perché accaduto questo
ci sono tante tantissime ragioni alcune
di queste hanno a che vedere con
fenomeni demografici erano stati
costruiti spesso questi quartieri per
ceti popolari ma fatti da famiglie
spesso grandi di lavoratori che erano
impegnati prevalentemente nel settore
industriale
la cambiamento demografico ha portato da
una parte all'invecchiamento dall'altra
parte alla presenza di nuove popolazioni
prevalentemente ma non solo straniere e
questo ha portato a difficoltà anche di
natura culturale
il degrado fisico di questi contesti
soprattutto quando è venuto meno un
importante impegno di risorse pubbliche
ha comportato gravissimi problemi di
manutenzione degli spazi soprattutto
dello spazio pubblico
e poi naturalmente questi quartieri nel
corso del tempo hanno anche subito la
crisi economica hanno subito le
difficoltà di molte di queste famiglie
insomma si è trattato di un sogno perché
molto spesso questi quartieri avevano
questa dimensione utopica di un sogno
che è diventato un incubo che è
diventato un luogo di difficoltà di
criticità come si fa a lavorare in
questi contesti come si fa a fare sì che
le periferie possano effettivamente
diventare anche una condizione di vita
positiva possano ritornare ad essere
parte di un sogno di una città migliore
e non è semplice naturalmente ci sono
molte cose che si possono raccontare a
questo proposito io vorrei farlo
narrando di alcune brevi storie con
riferimento a milano che è l'unica città
che conosco davvero bene in realtà vi
mostrerò cioè delle esperienze
attraverso le quali in condizioni di cui
non dobbiamo dimenticare mai la
difficoltà mai però c'è una
mobilitazione di forze locali e non
locali che sono in grado di generare
innovazione che sono in grado di
generare anche cose positive e vi farò
vedere una rapida carrellata di questo
tipo di esempi
azione integrata nelle periferie che
permette di costruire qualcosa di
positivo in questi contesti questo è
un'esperienza che abbiamo fatto proprio
noi al politecnico ma ping san siro
abbiamo preso in affitto un negozio
abbandonato all'interno di un quartiere
di edilizia pubblica e l'abbiamo messo a
disposizione dei nostri ricercatori dei
nostri studenti dei nostri dottorandi ed
è diventato una sorta di luogo aperto
del quartiere mapping san siro e cioè è
diventato un pezzo di università che si
fa città e che si fa città dentro le
periferie in questo caso è l'università
che si è fatta protagonista di un nuovo
modo di intendere di interpretare
l'azione educativa
l'azione formativa e la ricerca in
contesti di questo tipo
questo non è un altro caso abbastanza
noto si tratta di una cascina prossima a
una zona periferica di milano nell'ovest
milanese e prossimo un intervento di
housing sociale
l'operatore una fondazione che ha
promosso questo intervento di housing
sociale ha assegnato ad un'associazione
culturale la gestione di questa
cooperativa che si chiama mare culturale
urbano e questo luogo è diventato
insieme un luogo del tempo libero per
passare le serate ma anche un luogo di
produzione culturale un luogo di
produzione
diciamo dal punto di vista anche
economico è diventato uno spazio urbano
interessante in questo caso l'attore che
si è messo in moto non è un attore
pubblico ma un attore privato per quanto
molto particolare come una fondazione
questa è una via piuttosto nota a milano
si chiama via padova è una delle zone
più multietniche nell'estrema periferia
nord est della nostra città nel quale i
problemi della sicurezza sono stati
percepiti fortissimamente nel corso del
tempo ci sono stati anche degli eventi
violenti
quello che è interessante che la rete
delle associazioni ei gruppi che si sono
mobilitati che si sono mossi in via
padova hanno costruito tutta una serie
di azioni ed iniziative che hanno
portato a questo slogan che mi piace
molto che dice via padova è meglio di
milano perché si è sempre detto che
naturalmente via padova è un luogo
marginale estremo è invece l'idea che si
possa dire che via padova è meglio
milano segnala che c'è una rete molto
forte attiva di attori che può
mobilitarsi per rendere questi luoghi
belli interessanti attrattivi questo è
un quartiere che si chiama crocetta st
cinisello balsamo nord di milano comune
di prima cintura nel quale gli stranieri
sono all'incirca la metà della
popolazione non è un quartiere pubblico
un quartiere privato quindi
particolarmente difficile intervenire in
un contesto come questo
eppure al quartiere crocetta anche
grazie all'azione della pubblica
amministrazione del comune si stanno
mobilitando tutta una serie di risorse
di attori di iniziative a questa è la
festa del quartiere nel quale in un
contesto di grandissima difficoltà anche
di difficoltà di relazione fra etnie
diverse ce ne sono quasi 100 presenti
all'interno del quartiere si può pensare
di costruire qualcosa insieme di con
vivere di vivere insieme questo è
un'altra un altro elemento fondamentale
la periferia anche un luogo di un
patrimonio culturale storico artistico
straordinario e spesso poco conosciuto è
sottoutilizzato
questa è una bellissima cascina nel sud
di milano nel comune di rozzano che è
stata recuperata come biblioteca ed è un
esempio del fatto che anche il
patrimonio può diventare un elemento
importante fondamentale di lavoro questo
un quartiere molto famoso ponte lambro
nel quale un contratto di quartiere
promosso dalla pubblica amministrazione
ha costruito le condizioni di un
cambiamento
quando l'ho conosciuto io ho tanti anni
fa era un quartiere in cui non si poteva
mettere piede oggi è un quartiere
naturalmente con ancora molti problemi
ma forte e vivace questo ancora una
volta il politecnico e in questo caso è
un fab lab cioè un luogo di produzione
di lavoro costruito dal politecnico in
periferia nella zona di bovisa e anche
questo è molto importante lavorare nelle
periferie con le agente delle periferie
voliere anche dare ma ne parleranno
altri dopo di me condizioni di lavoro di
lavoro di buon lavoro per le persone che
ci vivono
e questa infine una scuola e la scuola
dei miei figli a dir la verità e tengo a
dire che le scuole sono dei degli
eccezionali luoghi per le periferie
perché sono luoghi nei quali i bambini e
ragazzini si integrano necessariamente
molto di più che altri e spesso le
energie che le famiglie ai genitori il
personale i docenti presidi
mettono all'interno delle scuole è
eccezionalmente forte e quindi le scuole
possono diventare delle sorte di abb che
all'interno dei quartieri all'interno
delle zone periferiche io abito ancora
abbastanza in periferia sono in grado di
generare di costruire relazioni reti
iniziative culturali condizioni di
coesione
insomma le periferie possono essere
anche dei luoghi nei quali insieme
insieme si produce innovazione e si
costruiscono condizioni di coesione di
coesione sociale di coesione
generazionale non è semplice non bastano
i gesti degli architetti non basta una
politica puramente sicuritaria ci
vogliono tante cose diverse ci vuole
molta pazienza ci vuole molto tempo ci
vuole molta cura ci vogliono risorse
pubbliche soldi pubblici
però da soli non bastano ci vuole anche
una capacità di attivazione di
mobilitazione della società delle
risorse degli attori delle associazioni
di tutti coloro che si muovono nel
territorio
a queste condizioni e naturalmente anche
questo è un altro esempio di un di un
laboratorio nel quartiere gallaratese
questo è un parco però non ho tempo per
farvi rivedere tutti a queste condizioni
io credo che un altra periferia sia
possibile naturalmente ripeto non
dimenticando le condizioni di
materialità delle criticità e delle
difficoltà ma assumendo con forza che le
periferie possono anche essere un luogo
di ricchezza di ricchezza di relazione
di ricchezza di umanità e di ricchezza
intesa anche come capacità di produrre
lo ripeto insieme coesione sociale e
innovazione grazie
[Applauso]